- Hey, everyone. Welcome.
We're excited to have you join
us for a conversation today
that sits at the
intersection of technology,
finance, and the future of mobility.
Today, we're joined by leaders
who are helping redefine
what it means to run finance
inside of technology-driven EV company.
I'll let the panel introduce themselves,
but we're excited to have Aditya and Wil
from Lucid Motors join
us here on the stage.
Lucid is a company
that's not just building
electric vehicles,
but reimagining what a digital
first auto manufacturer
looks like.
Lucid and PwC have been
leveraging AWS services
to establish proof of concepts
across the finance organization
with solutions targeting all
levels of the organization.
From the board of directors
and C-suites to the analysts,
they're moving fast and
pushing their organization
to move at Sapphire speed.
For those of you who aren't
familiar with Sapphire speed,
Sapphire is the premium level
of the successful Lucid Air,
and it's known for its
acceleration from zero to 60
in under two seconds, which
I need to experience that.
It's my ask.
Today, we're gonna talk
through the journey
that they're on adopting AI
in their finance organization.
So, let's just jump in.
Let's start with a round of introductions.
If we can start closest
to me with you, Aditya,
and go on down.
- Sure. Thanks, and thanks for having us.
And we're very excited to be
here and share our experiences.
My name is Aditya Baheti.
I head the business finance team at Lucid,
which spans across
corporate finance functions,
systems finance, which is where
much of the agentic AI work
is being done along with
other finance functions.
- Hello, I'm Wil Velez.
I work with Aditya at Lucid,
and I focus on developing
our finance systems,
and that's how I got
involved with this project.
- And you have not mentioned
that you just got back from India, right?
- I did.
- I think it's important. (laughs)
- I did get back from India last night,
and I'm still recovering from my jet lag,
so please excuse me if
I'm a little bit slow.
(Lori laughs)
- So, I'm Lori Driscoll.
I run our PwC's tech media and
telecom consulting business,
which essentially is anything
that we do with our customers
from IPO readiness through
to the agentic journey
across a number of different
functions, including finance.
- And Brad Donaldson with PwC.
I'm the practice leader for
our finance solutions offering,
which the fun part of my role
is that we get to oversee
all these different programs
we have at different
clients that are ongoing.
- Awesome. Excited to
have everybody with us.
For the audience, my name is Adam Hood.
I help lead our data and AI
capability focused on AWS.
Excited to be here with you
today with its great audience.
Aditya, I wanna start with you.
I think everybody's familiar with Lucid.
You guys make exceptional cars
that are truly in a category
of one, but for our audience,
do you mind sharing a
little bit more about Lucid,
like share a little bit
about your journey, perhaps,
you know, the new SUV,
and then maybe anything you wanna share
about a future mid-size
SUV that might be coming?
- Absolutely, absolutely.
Well, Sapphire, as you mentioned,
is less than, you know,
two seconds from zero to 60.
If you're still in the
market for a sedan, you know,
you can do touring and grand touring,
which is less than three seconds.
Having said that, Lucid
is a software EV company,
software-defined EV company,
and it's been selling
Lucid Air sedan since 2021.
And it's rated one of
the best luxury EV cars
in the industry.
In fact, it's received many of,
post of the accolades and the rewards
and recognitions from
the automotive industry.
We introduced Gravity earlier this year,
which has also received
incredible reviews and feedback
and many more accolades and
recognitions to follow through.
Now, what we are doing is, you know,
we're culminating all our technology
and performance into a soon
to be available next year,
introducing mid-size platform
at much more affordable prices,
which will unleash a whole
lot of massive growth
for the company.
I think in addition to
just developing cars,
pride itself also in developing, you know,
having competitive edge technology,
not just in terms of like
performance, range, drive,
or you know, the space,
but also in terms of defining
the future of mobility
or transportation.
By that, I mean enabling or giving sort
of autonomous driving
cars directly to consumers
in partnership with NVIDIA that
we just recently announced.
Additionally, we're also
doing Robotaxi fleets
in partnership with Nuro and
Uber, which will, you know,
we've announced Bay Area
to be the first launch city
by the end of next year.
I would also mention that every car
that is sold in USA is made in USA,
so it's a made in US company as well.
So there's a lot of excitement at Lucid,
and we're really looking forward to it.
- That's fantastic. Thank
you for the context.
Maybe just to keep moving on,
I think you talked about
the growth and the scale.
You talked about what
you're doing here in the US,
but you guys are scaling globally, right?
You know, you've taken on a lot
of really important impactful
initiatives around AI,
specifically within finance.
What made now the right time
to dig into those initiatives
and take on so many of them at once?
- No, that's a good question. Why now?
Of course, I think one,
we're preparing ourself
for the massive growth
or the growth that is gonna
unfold or unleash, you know,
with launch of mid-size cars
and finance organization
as a function needs to scale
to support that growth in
a more sustainable way.
So that's sort of the main driver.
But in addition to that,
we also have a CFO's
vision transforming finance
into much more of a competitive edge
and provide more real time
analytics, business insights,
to be driving more
data-driven decision making
in a very fast-paced environment
and in uncertain environment,
especially this year where
we've experienced tariffs
and trade impacts and
other sort of unforeseen,
unplanned events and activities.
- That's fantastic.
I think you've started to
touch on, one thing I wanted,
maybe Lori, you or Brad can jump in here,
provide a perspective.
I think you just started
to touch on the vision
that drives these decisions,
especially around finance
transformation and AI.
Like, what do you see more broadly
around what's driving the impact,
what's driving the excitement around AI
at the intersection of finance?
And maybe we'll come back
and talk about specifically
how that vision is driving at Lucid.
- Yeah, and I think a couple of things.
One, you know, finance
organizations are constantly
under cost pressures like many
of the other back office functions.
So, you know, you've
got the responsibility
of closing the books
and reporting results,
but at the same time,
you're trying to make sure
that you're a good business partner
and providing decision support
to the operations teams.
And so when you think about
that ever-evolving pressure,
you know, it's how do I
start to leverage better,
smarter ways to go about doing this?
And also as I'm doing it,
increase the amount of insights
that I'm able to provide to the business.
So it's kind of that inflection point here
where you can get a kind of a double win
where you can help grow
scale without scaling
from a headcount basis,
but at the same time,
scale with capabilities.
The other thing I would
add is that, you know,
I spend a lot of time
meeting with different CFOs
and it's really at a board level right now
where a lot of the boards
are requesting the CFOs of,
you know, how are you
thinking about AI, right?
There's the AI from the
perspective of governance, right?
When you talk about financials,
and we've got, you know,
regulated numbers are getting put out,
how do we control
anything that's AI-driven
that's gonna be put inside
the financial systems?
And so there's the control perspective
that they're looking at, but
then they're also looking
at how are we leveraging it to give
that competitive advantage, you know,
what are the opportunities there?
And so a lot of the conversations
with CFOs around starting
to go down that path of
how do they get started,
how do they embed that,
what's the path going forward?
- Really good stuff.
Aditya,
like, when you and Wil embark
on this journey, right?
Like, how did you imagine the
future of finance at Lucid,
like, what drove some of those,
like, what was that process like for you?
What was the vision behind it?
What do you hope that
looks like in the future?
- Yeah, I mean, and, you know,
he touched on that in terms
of being a competitive edge,
you know, finance can be
a catalyst for growth.
I think that's the sort of vision we have,
and I think by that, you break
it down into sort of smaller,
you know, bite-size tactical
things such as, you know,
the amount of data that finance
sees and acts has access to,
not just within the finance domain,
but also outside of finance domain,
there is a huge potential
to unlock the capability
of providing real time
predictive analytics
leveraging the AI tools,
and there's so much value to
be unlocked, just, you know,
having better decision making capability.
Second, I would also
say the ability to adapt
and adjust very quickly.
You know, we have multiple sort
of ways of doing, you know,
scenario planning, with
so much uncertainty,
so much sort of unplanned
activity, you know,
we're always trying to assess
our risk profile, you know,
and multiple scenario
planning gives us the ability
not only just plan, but also
quantify the level of risk,
and therefore we can
proactively manage those risks
to be able to execute to our
sort of vision and strategy.
So I think that's the sort
of vision that we have
on the finance side, to be
more of a competitive edge,
but also be a catalyst for growth.
- And I would add one more thing on,
like, on a broader agenda,
we mentioned the board,
when you take a look at the F500,
the Fortune 500 companies
over the last three years,
any company that has
invested more than 0.5%
in AI has had a 21% or more
total shareholder value return.
That's a phenomenal return on investment.
Now, a lot of us are piloting
and experimenting over
the last several years.
2025, I think has been
a turning point in terms
of more purposeful investments
in agents and workflows
that make a difference for
functions like finance.
But the returns are there.
So we've got the proof in the pudding,
and that's why boards are asking
for more dollars to be spent.
- Absolutely. I agree with that.
And we're seeing the early
results such with the work
that we've been doing with
PwC and AWS. (indistinct)
- I'll just add, when the
PwC brought this project idea
to us, our first meeting
with our C-suite, Taoufiq,
our CFO, ended the meeting with,
sometimes you have to
take a leap of faith,
and that's exactly what
he allowed us to do,
he enabled us to do.
And the success that we're
seeing now is powerful.
- No, and I would just say,
by no means I think we're experts,
we're just sharing experiences
over here, so don't,
you know,
I think everybody's experience
can be very different,
but this space is evolving
at a very rapid pace.
So I would say like, you know,
what's relevant for us may
not be relevant tomorrow,
but we're just sharing experiences.
- One thing I'll add is,
when I first got involved with the team,
I was looking at, and they're
just breakneck speed, right?
The rate at which they were going,
it made me a little nervous at first.
And what I found was is that
they're able to do that,
because he touched on one
of the very critical points,
which is they had executive alignment
at the top level to go.
And so we would be in meetings
and there'd be a discussion
of something we needed,
and, you know, their CIO
would be on his phone.
Yep, by the time we
get back to the office,
there was getting access to that data set
or what we're looking for.
So it really enabled the team to do that.
But I think it's really
critical when we talk
about the story is, is that
to do something like this,
you do have to have that top-down buy-in.
- Yeah, fantastic.
I mean, I think everyone
associates an engineering-led kind
of software-defined automaker
mentality with Lucid, right?
And you're describing
what I would consider some
of the obvious traits of an organization
that describes themselves as such.
Like, maybe you can talk just a little bit
about how that culture, that identity,
like, connects with this work.
Like, how does this
vision around an agentic
enabled finance team align
with your broader organization strategy?
- Yeah, I would say innovation is at sort
of the core central theme at Lucid.
You know, you see it in the
cars in being the best cars
and you know, with
excellent sort of features
and capabilities, it has
the competitive edge.
And I think from a technology standpoint,
it's pushing itself, you know,
it's always pushing its
boundaries in terms of like,
you know, now looking at
the future of mobility
and transportation by providing, you know,
autonomous cars directly to the consumers,
not just the Robotaxis and the
fleets through Uber and Nuro,
but also, you know, hands
off, minds off, eyes off,
kind of like a, you know,
L4 autonomous experience,
driving experience.
I think with, if you carry
that same sort of philosophy,
finance organization is sort
of in the same boat in terms
of pushing its boundaries,
in terms of innovation,
and you leveraging, you know,
the technologies of the tools
that are available to us in
a more cost efficient way.
We're planning for growth and you know,
we're investing in growth,
but in a more sustainable and
a more cost efficient way.
- Yeah, Brad, I would just ask,
I think that culture of innovation,
even within the finance organization,
like, not every organization
has that, right?
But what are we seeing more
broadly? Is this a trend?
Is this the start of
something across finance?
- I mean, I think, I mean,
Lucid is in a little bit
of a unique situation in
the fact that, you know,
relatively new company, tech focused.
And so the adoption was
much, much higher, right?
I think it's all culture
specific to each company.
And as we think about it and
we start to go down that path
to get the adoption and buy-in,
there's different ways
we have to think through,
how are we going to do that?
And I mean, I've worked with clients
where we've developed some amazing tools
to help them drive profitability
and predict profitability,
and then finance would
solve the problem they had,
and then operations would
take it going forward.
Like, well, that's a great
tool, we'll use it now.
And then finance didn't because
they were used to going,
I gotta close the books and
then I do my reports and then I,
so it really is driving a cultural change,
and it has to be thinking
through, you know, in their space,
very fortunate to be able to do that.
But other companies, we
have to think through,
like, how are we gonna drive
that change and drive adoption?
- Real quick, let's move
into some of the discussion
about maybe some of the
use cases specifically,
like, you're taking on a
lot of prototypes early.
I think there's 14 different
use cases you're starting
with out of the gate.
A lot of our clients may think
about starting with one or two.
Lucid is not an organization
that moves slow.
So you're taking on 14.
I'm really curious about,
have you taken on these
early prototypes and demos?
Has there been any of 'em in particular
that have generated kinda
the strongest excitement
internally and why is that?
- Sure. We didn't plan for 14,
it just so happened to be 14.
(laughs)
We actually started with our pain points,
and pain points in terms
of what's stopping us from,
you know, delivering that growth,
supporting that growth or
scaling the finance organization
to deliver that growth.
And, you know, there
were very critical areas
that we could clearly identify
and needed to be addressed.
You know, some of those,
the use cases that you're,
you know, you mentioned about, you know,
there are actually few of them
that are worth mentioning,
one of them being demand-
- They're all worth mentioning by the way.
(audience laughing)
- You're right, because they
all address the pain points.
But demand forecasting, actually,
all of them are super important.
Demand forecasting, I'll
talk a little bit about that,
because I've had experience
with building an AI model even,
you know, almost like a decade
ago with Berkeley students
and we used some random
forest sort of algorithms
and you know, the compute and
the resources were so limited
that you could only use finite files,
finite attributes, and finite files,
and it would take like days
to just refresh the model.
Fast forward like 15
years, especially 2025,
I think the resources are
now changing and available
at a much more sort of
larger, you know, speeds,
so that the turnaround, the
speed has become very critical
for us, which helps
faster decision making.
So demand forecasting is one
that I would talk about more
in detail as we, you know,
go through this session.
The other one is investor, you know,
analyst, dashboard, if you will.
What it does is it not
only talks about, you know,
the investing, the investor holdings,
but also the positions that
some of the investors are taking
in terms of sell or put options against,
and what it demonstrates,
it, you know, there are some,
let's say groups that are investing
against their own sister companies,
and why would one do that?
And that is bringing, that
is reducing the volatility
of our stock prices that can be leveraged
for a lot more sort of,
you know, proof points.
And I think that has been
a significant use case.
I mean, Wil, there's more, I
know all of them are important.
You wanna talk a little bit about-
- Not specifically, but
we've worked on these cons,
these POCs across treasury, accounting,
finance, internal audit.
There are a number of examples
where we're gonna drive efficiencies,
improve accuracy, and speed things up.
I think those are the
important talking points.
We will continue to
leverage this technology
and as Aditya pointed out
earlier, we're not experts.
We're learning as we
go. This is a journey.
And the fortunate thing is
our, like you mentioned,
our C-suite is onboard and
empowering us to do this,
which is important.
- I would also add the
orchestration layer, right?
So we just put that in
place last week for Lucid.
So it's early stages,
but the goal is it's never
about the agents themselves,
it's about the outcomes
that the agents deliver.
And in a multi-agent environment,
you need a common
orchestration layer to be able
to provide safeguard,
guardrails, policy adherence,
agent to agent, you know,
lanes for them to work
together across workflows,
and be able to produce results.
So one of the things
like, we're at re:Invent,
the great news, what we
put in place is agent OS,
which is built and provided by PwC,
but it's native to AWS,
embedded with Bedrock.
It works with all the
integration points that you need.
And as we bring agents online,
they work with one another.
And that's the goal, right?
You're not gonna have 10 agents,
you're gonna have hundreds
of agents every time.
- That's a great point.
Thanks for,
we're gonna continue to
unpack that a little bit more,
so let's talk about that one.
You shared a travel story.
We're all passionate travelers up here.
We were able to align on that.
You shared a story about
using ChatGPT around travel.
It was really good 'cause we
were talking about, you know,
how this journey, like,
there's things on this journey
that have surprised you
about how it's reshaping
the day-to-day impact on finance.
And I thought you shared a great example.
Do you mind kind of
unpacking that for us again?
- Sure, sure, sure.
So I just came back from India
and I was sharing a story
this morning with Adam,
but, so I went to India,
I went to Jaipur and I asked ChatGPT,
hey, give me an itinerary
for three days as a tourist.
It, you know, very nicely
gave me a three, you know,
page itenerary for three
days and say, hit this spot,
hit this spot, hit this spot.
Say, okay, great.
Then I said, well, I'm
traveling with all the parents,
so give me a revised version of the chat.
It just said, just go slow.
(audience laughing)
I said, okay, great, that's helpful.
What it didn't do was when I
spoke and when I got there,
you know, I met the locals over there
and they actually told me
exactly what to do and you know,
which shops to hit, what
to do from one location
to another location, take
like the three-wheeler
or the two-wheeler or
what have you, right?
Do not go to these restaurants.
So there's a lot of things
that were there that needed
to be, you know, that I
learned from the locals.
This is the parallel
I draw from, you know,
the work we are doing
on the agentic AI side.
I think a lot of the work gets leveraged
through an automated way
the machine can learn,
but there will always be, at
least in my experience so far
using these models has been
that there will be a human touch,
which almost is similar
to the locals in a city
to provide that business context.
We know our business the
very, you know, best,
and it's very unique for us.
So we have to provide
that relevant experience
or data points for those models to work.
And the efficiencies of those
models will only improve
over time, just like,
way more took 10 years to
build an autonomous cut
while we just started
the journey right now.
And I'm not saying it'll take 10 years,
but at least you know,
it's gonna take time for it to be perfect.
But we see a world as you said, like,
hey, what are some of
the learnings over here?
We see a world that where AI is augmenting
the work that finance team is doing
and not replacing them completely.
Second, I think the finance
team now has much more speed
and bandwidth to focus
on business insights
to be truly a leader as well
as strategic business partner,
and then drive more data
based decision making.
So I would say that, you know,
this is where I feel like,
the learnings have been immense.
We're constantly improving our models,
the accuracy of the models, and you know,
and that's a journey as I
think we'll call it out.
- I mean, we talked about it earlier,
the more we enable technology
to any degree automation,
the agentic journey orchestration,
the more human we need
to be as leaders, right?
So it's not just the freeing
our time up for strategy,
it's the reasonableness.
You still have hallucinations
in a lot of the models
that cannot be relied on
for every business decision
out there.
It's more than just a starting point
because even the progress
that we've made in the last,
I feel like the last 12
months has changed all
of the functions across
most of our companies.
But that means that us as leaders have to,
the empathy that we need to show up with,
we talked a little bit earlier,
the people part of this,
I've never seen a moment,
and I've been doing this now
for too long, I think 33 years.
I've never seen a moment
where the uncertainty,
because of the potential impact on jobs,
because of the potential impact
on your children's ability
to pursue careers that exist today,
that uncertainty has led
to just a lot of angst.
One of the things that we're rolling out,
I wasn't gonna mention this,
but now that I'm thinking about it,
we've invested a lot to
roll out a program in 2026,
where we're doing all the upskilling
that everybody else is doing,
and I think we're actually ahead in terms
of disrupting our own business,
but we're putting a lot of money toward,
I think it's 15 points around
a human-centered, you know,
circle in terms of, and
it's not just empathy,
it's coaching through uncertainty,
it's coaching when
technology changes workflows
on a very real time basis.
So the skills that we
have are a lot of things
that we were taught kind of
early on in terms of being kind
and helping bring people
along for the journey.
I think it's more important than ever.
- No, absolutely.
And I would add to that, like, I mean,
it will require us to rescale.
I mean, at least in the
finance organization,
I can talk about that.
You know, it's not just gonna
be about reporting numbers
and doing the reconciliations.
It's gonna be about, you know,
how do we leverage the
tool we have and you know,
be more strategic about it.
And I think it's the right way.
I draw, you know, analogy
from like when we used
to do mental math and then
calculators were introduced,
everybody thought, oh my
god, my job's gonna be gone.
Well, it just enhanced your productivity.
Well, AI is going to
take that to, you know,
maybe 10x or you know, 50x fold in terms
of enhancing productivity,
but you will need, you
know, some level of touch,
human touch in there, and humans
and the workforce will have
to be retrained knowing how
to leverage this technology.
And, you know, maybe I'll also mention
about the demand forecasting
tool that we are, I mean,
I'll dive a little bit deeper into that,
because in my experience when we,
demand forecasting generally
is, I've seen at least in three
of my sort of experiences is
one of the most popular ways,
because very often, the CFOs,
the CEOs want to know what
their revenue is gonna be,
either for next month,
next quarter, next year,
or next five years, you know,
and the trigger for
revenue is for them to know
what the demand is gonna
look like and you know,
you can build price elasticity,
demand curves, and whatnot.
So far, you know, up until now,
we were able to take internal factors.
We could do some sort of
basic trend level analysis
and look at a, we have
these existing products,
this is gonna scale this
way and this, you know,
expect this kind of sort
of, GDP is growing X,
inflation going Y, you
know, assume sort of,
and some level of growth over there.
What we've done, I think with
this sort of agentic model is,
to be able to combine and
correlate both the external
and the internal factors
in one sort of platform.
And, you know, the external
factors are also not just about,
you know, you can take CPI, GDP growth,
for us, it's gas prices.
Some are lagging indicators,
but some are leading indicators.
So you know, drop in gas
prices negatively impacts EV,
increase in gas prices,
positively impacts.
So those are sort of leading
indicators, you know,
interest rate drops
that sort of, you know,
those are correlations you can make
through leading and lagging.
You match that against, you
know, incentives and discounts
and pricing offers that
we're giving in addition
to the order taker rate,
the pipeline that we have.
And you build multiple
sort of statistical models,
layer on top of that and
be able to, you know,
run those scenarios in
a fraction of a second.
I think that's breakthrough technology.
That's what I think will
give us the competitive edge.
To give you an example,
I think you mentioned about
hallucination, you know,
the EV credits were taken
away in September 30th.
The models assumed
that this event happens
every September 30th.
Well, this is where the
humans come into play.
They say, no, no, no,
this is a one-time event,
one-time activity.
Maybe the demand has accelerated,
maybe, you know, October,
November, December is gonna
go look very different.
So those are the things,
this is exactly like, I mean,
similar to COVID period,
right out of COVID,
nobody knew how the
demand is gonna shape out,
and everybody planned for the worst,
and we ended up being
in supply chain crisis.
So I would say there's that element
that will always be there.
- That makes a ton of sense.
But for the record, zero
to 60 in under two seconds
and 400 plus miles of range, like,
that's the only indicator I needed.
Like, I'm in.
- We compromise nothing.
- That's right. Well done.
Maybe let's pivot a little bit
to the technology discussion
a little bit more.
Lori, you started to take us there.
Maybe we spent a few more minutes on that.
Wil, I'd love to get you to
weigh in a little bit as well.
Like, there's a lot of
organizations that we work with,
that maybe they adopt
packaged finance solutions.
There's a lot of solutions out there
for finance professionals.
We've talked about RPA and
the role that it can play
in accelerating value
creation for finance teams,
but you guys have chose
to be on the leading edge.
So what was it that convinced you
that an agentic approach powered by AWS
was a compelling path to go on?
- For us, it boiled down to
we knew we had access to data.
We learned that after engaging PwC
and they showed us that
as a finance organization,
you have so much more data
than you are familiar with.
Yes, of course we run on SAP,
and so we're intimately
familiar with that,
but there was a ton of wealth on Redshift
that the PwC brought to our attention
that unlocked a lot of value for us.
And as that conversation grew,
we became more interested
in agentic, and now,
the solutions that we've
developed have really proven
that if you can unlock that data
that is captured all
throughout the company,
not just within finance,
we're leveraging data from Salesforce
and other platforms that's
really empowering us
to build solutions that add
a lot of value for finance.
- Fantastic.
Lori or Brad, anything you
wanna jump in on there?
- I always go broader.
Like, I look at it as a, like,
when the wave of
investments came for cloud
and cloud infrastructure, you
know, at that moment in time,
you're spending a lot of time
on your technology
architecture to make sure
that the pipes work, to make
sure you're thinking about it
in a way where the total
cost of ownership makes sense
for the company.
The shift now oftentimes has been,
I think in 2023 and 2024
definitely had a lot of companies
that were experimenting.
There were a lot of pilots
that were going on even through '25.
I think the word purposeful
and disciplined I think
become really important
when you talk about agentic
because it's not just the use cases,
the use cases are really
important because they're the one,
they're your path to drive an outcome.
But what's equally
important is making sure
that the new architecture makes sense
so that you're gaining access,
the integration points are there to data
across the business,
potentially in most cases data
that far exceeds anything that
you've ever had access to.
But you also have the scalability
and the performance long term.
I always look at the
economics associated with it.
So if you think about GPUs,
and it's hard to look at the
news without a conversation
in terms of semiconductor industry
and supply chain challenges and the like.
You've gotta be really smart in terms
of how you build the journey
because there's only so much capacity
that's gonna be available,
at least in the near term.
And so for that, one of the
things that we've been doing
with clients is what needs to
run on a large language model
versus what might be able
to run on an edge solution,
and starting to architect
different technologies
or different solutions
depending upon the workflow.
I think that's gonna be really important
in the coming months and years
because we will have capacity
challenges based on the energy
that's gonna be required in order
to run what we think is gonna be a, yeah,
a massive change for all of the companies
that are represented in this realm.
- Fantastic.
I think again, moving at the
speed that you're moving,
I think it's important
maybe for the audience
like this wasn't,
this project that we're
discussing out of the gate,
like, this wasn't a two-year project
to enable edge into capabilities, right?
Like, this was 10 weeks,
something like that, right?
Like, what is it that allows
you to move that fast?
Is it a particular technology?
Is it your organization is,
I'd love to think it was your partners,
but what is it gonna help?
- It's also our partners. It's our org.
It's our culture.
We run, we move at a
really quick fast pace.
And I always joke with people
when I'm interviewing them is
they have to be comfortable
with not knowing what
they're gonna do tomorrow.
As an example, I did not
know I'd be on this stage
when I woke up this morning,
but that's the pace we work at.
And I've been with EV
startups for eight years.
It's been like that every single year.
It's constantly changing.
We're developing, we're
trying to disrupt a very old
industry and we're using
cutting edge technology.
And so the pace, I
cannot emphasize enough,
it's extremely fast,
and you have to be able to
adapt with that quickly.
And if you can, you'll catch
on to things like this.
- I think the other thing
just to add though is,
when we're talking about the
technology is that, you know,
finance professionals
have been doing their role
for a long time
and they don't really
understand the capabilities
that are being unlocked.
And so the battle that I
always run into with clients
is getting them to think differently.
Like, how do I, like for instance,
if we think about I close
the books on a monthly basis.
I do my (indistinct) on a monthly basis.
I do, why, I mean we could automate
and do a lot of that stuff daily.
We can start to go to a continuous close.
We can start, there's all these things
that we've just gotta make the edge,
I'd say one is educate
the finance professionals
around what is the capabilities today.
And then two, encourage them
and support them in thinking
of about what are the other
things I can dream of,
what are the things that we can try to do?
And then a culture that supports
it such that when he said,
hey, we take a leap of
faith, that's so critical.
- Yeah, and I would just add
to that, I think as Wil said,
like, I think the speed is important,
but I think the exec
sponsorship alignment,
leadership sort of, you know,
support is super critical
for any such projects to be successful.
And once you get that, I think
you have to move very quickly
and you have to iterate fast.
You have to fail fast if you will.
And learn and adapt and tweak models.
It'll never be perfect 'cause you know,
that will just take time
and I would say, you know,
adjust those models and make it, you know,
if it's 80% there, I
think it's a good start,
and you keep iterating on that.
- In order to keep moving at that speed,
we often talk about the
importance of governance,
specifically in the
finance function, right?
And governance takes many forms,
whether it's the organizational structure,
the people governance,
or whether it's what the
technology enables us to do.
We've talked a lot at this
at the re:Invent this year,
talking about automated
reasoning as part of agent core
and things like that.
We're excited,
you guys are implementing
some of those things.
Maybe give us some thoughts
on just the governance
controls responsible portion
of the discussion specifically,
'cause we're talking about
finance, it's critical.
- It's not just finance.
It really is a collaboration
across so many teams.
I can tell you, being on this project,
I've worked with and have now become very,
very close to a number of different teams
that I did not know existed
prior to this project,
cybersecurity, infrastructures,
internal audit, you name it.
Everyone had to get involved
and align on what needs
to happen in order to enable this.
And so once you get that
cross-functional alignment,
I think it's much more feasible.
- And I think, you know, IT,
and we have a dedicated AI
team understanding, you know,
laying out the architecture
and the cost sort of economics
of it as Lori mentioned,
but weekly check-ins,
making sure that, you know,
you unblock all your barriers,
you know, very sort of,
you know, methodical and timely way.
And of course, cybersecurity,
security is super important over here.
I mean we're talking about AI,
but we also wanna make sure we, you know,
our models are safe and,
you know, good for use.
- He's joking. He said weekly check-ins.
There were 8:00 AM calls every day.
So it was not weekly, it was daily.
- There was only so many weeks. (laughs)
I mean, you guys are moving so quickly,
daily seems appropriate.
Lori, how does this line up with-
- Yeah, I also see, like,
sometimes I'm surprised,
like, I'll get on a call
and see a demo of something
that we've built with customers.
It's interesting 'cause
it's different dependent
upon what a company
wants to spend money on.
And so I'd love to think we shape that,
but oftentimes we're on the receiving end
of what a company is willing to do
and when they're willing to do it
and how fast they're willing to do it.
In this particular case,
it's been fun for everybody
because of the pace, may
not always feel that way,
but the outcome has been there,
because you're seeing things
in action faster than we ever have.
But I was on a call a couple weeks ago
and one of my teams was walking me
through what I would consider
if there's internal auditors
in the room, then forgive me,
but what I would consider
to be kind of mundane work
in terms of controls testing that you have
to do on a regular basis and it's rotating
and still sample sizes
and all that good stuff.
We took something that used to
take 20 days to test down to,
they were telling me it was
two minutes and they said,
our goal is that it's gonna
be less than 20 seconds.
And that's what we're working on right now
with the right kind of
guardrails and you know,
and making sure the reasonableness
checks are there as well.
You get to do a larger
population in a very short amount
of time, which frees up
internal auditors to think
about where the risks are in the business
and help the company protect
against malicious intent
of which unfortunately
that's going up as well.
- Maybe if you can just
continue that thought,
think about the next, you
know, 12 months, two years,
what kind, like, what
are our clients expecting
in their finance organization
and more broadly?
And then I'd love to hear
like specifically to Lucid,
like, what are you guys thinking about?
You did this so quickly.
12 months seems like an
eternity at the speed you move.
- I mean, on most days,
I don't think we're moving fast enough.
So I think every single
function needs a backlog
and what you did in 10 weeks,
to me, that's the new model.
You're gonna be running sprints
and you're gonna be working
through that backlog
and you're going to iterate on solutions
that you may have built
in the first 10 weeks
are gonna seem archaic, you
know, 18 months from now,
not even 18 months from now.
I think, you know, one,
we try and avoid lock-in.
So most enterprises have multiple
models that are available
to them, some of which are for economics,
others are for kind of purposeful intent
in terms of the outcome that
you're trying to deliver.
I think that's gonna be
important. It is a race.
So it depends on the technology
providers as well in terms
of, you know, who continues
to evolve the fastest in a way
that is gonna be meaningful
for your business across
certain functions.
The technology's moving
quickly and I think, you know,
just as much, we've gotta think through.
I love the discussion on growth
because oftentimes AI is
talked about as a cost lever.
So how do you drive more efficiency?
How do you potentially reduce head count?
That's not what it's about.
It's unlocking capacity and
it's unlocking a growth strategy
that's not available
today for most companies
because they do have a cap on headcount
and they do have a cap on capacity.
That's the part that's exciting to me.
- Yeah, and I think for Lucid,
as you, you know, call out,
it's pretty much in line
with that in terms of like,
you know, speed is
gonna be super critical,
and understanding, you
know, the ability to adapt
to market conditions,
changing market conditions
and providing real time analytics
and predictive analytics
or insights with, you know,
database decision making.
In terms of, you know, finance,
I believe will become
a catalyst for growth
because as I mentioned earlier,
like, it will unlock a lot
of data that, you know,
generally is connected
when everything flows
into a financial system, it is
flowing from multiple systems
and there's a, you know,
potential to unlock a lot
of value in terms of providing
valuable business insight.
Third, I think it also will
lay down the foundation for us
for finance organization to
be a competitive edge in,
you know, in the things
that I talked about.
And lastly I would say like, you know,
the finance organization will
truly be a strategic business
partner in, they would think
of them more as like the locals
in that story that I just mentioned.
They would be considered as
locals knowing their domain,
their expertise, their sort of area,
and be able to provide
that business context,
valuable business context
to those stakeholders,
important and critical for
decision making at every level.
- I mean, you're setting
the pace with finance,
which I don't get to say that very often.
Usually, I can't say
in most organizations,
finance is setting a pace around
AI, so kudos there, right?
But with that in mind, like,
where do you see the next
transformation taking place?
Like, is this gonna spill
over into factory ops
and supply chain?
Like, where is this headed?
- For Lucid, specifically, you know,
we've just started on
this journey and you know,
we have as I think Lori mentioned,
there's a backlog of items that, you know,
once you see the art of possible,
every team raises their
hand and they'll say like,
oh, I should be doing this,
I should be doing that.
I see factory operations
in terms of like, you know,
factory production, we manufacture
our own cars, you know,
in United States, and so
constraints around that,
supply chain constraints, you know,
we ran into a lot of like
critical parts like magnets
and things like that where, you know,
supplier health and things like that,
where that's another wave
of sort of, you know,
complexity that we will navigate through.
And above all, I also think,
I don't know what voice we'll
do in terms of AI capability,
you know, that's another
transformational sort
of cross point that
I'm looking forward to,
which might even further disrupt some
of the work we're doing over here.
- Yeah, I think we're seeing
speech to speech models
in particular becoming very
powerful and transformative.
So that's a good call out.
Maybe I'll throw this one out to anybody.
We touched on it a little bit,
but this is the human plus AI
element to the conversation.
Lori, I think you started to
unpack, this is about more,
not shaving down through efficiency,
particularly with the steep growth
that's projected for the Lucid team.
Like, how are we seeing
that come together both maybe
at Lucid or even more broadly?
- I mean, I think about
it from a perspective
of what is gonna differentiate
finance people going forward,
is their ability to
integrate with the technology
and the AI.
And I've said it a few times,
I just feel really strongly about it.
And that's where really
around thinking differently
around how they do their jobs.
And so it's how can, you know,
how can I be more impactful?
How can I identify more
value for the company?
How can I send better
signals to operations?
How can, all of these things,
which today, you know,
a lot of times old school
finance organizations
are really looking at,
they're reporting backward.
Like, how did we do last quarter?
How are we going against
plan? What is the difference?
But they're not saying,
what are those levers
that are driving the changes
and figure out how I change it.
So I look and I go, oh, I
gave you an EPS estimate of X,
I'm gonna be 7% lower.
How do I use AI to model
out different scenarios
of different behaviors to be able to see,
can I close that gap?
What levers can I pull?
What things can I do?
And it's the combination of the two,
which is really gonna drive value.
And so when folks think about, you know,
oh, there's the risk of efficiencies
that could impact my role.
I think about it a little
differently in the fact
that it's the combination of the two
that can really provide the value
for the financial
professional going forward.
And they can bring that insight
that just technology can't, right?
They know how to put those things together
and really differentiate themselves.
- The other element,
and we're saying that we just
did a benchmarking exercise
for a few of our clients.
You wanna look at the past,
you wanna be able to
scenario plan for the future.
You wanna look at your peer set,
you wanna look at best in class.
Oftentimes that took a long time to do.
And I think that it goes back to speed.
If you can ask a large
language model very quickly
to take a look through the Ks and the Qs,
and the analyst reports and the like,
in terms of what are the growth levers
that are out there that may
impact my business faster,
and am I missing something on
my cost structure associated
with, and the formulas that
I use in terms of the mix
of CapEx and opex and the like,
I think that's where the
creativity gets unlocked.
Like, for too long, there's a
lot of jobs that have become,
it's not that they're transactional,
but there's a lot of time
spent on the workflow itself
and it doesn't allow for,
you know, that's why when,
if you've slept eight
hours a night or seven
or eight hours a night,
which we should be doing,
and you wake up, they say,
do your hardest task first, right?
We're all tired when we're
trying to unlock that creativity,
oftentimes we're on the
other end of being very tired
with everything that's
going on in our lives.
If we can simplify how we get
the information in our hands
and the right information
to actually unlock
how the business should be
performing, that's what,
to your point in terms of
being a strategic partner
to the business, I think
that's gonna be the difference.
- Yeah, I mean at Lucid,
we do see a world with AI
as sort of augmenting the
finance team and especially,
you know, to drive the
growth in a more sustainable
and a cost efficient way.
Yeah.
- Yeah, makes a ton of sense.
I know we're getting close
on time, so I just want to-
- I think it's happy
hour for a lot of people.
- Is it? It's happy hour for me, always.
Let's talk about, one last good question.
I'd like to just go down,
and let you guys give some quick thoughts.
A lot of people may be
in the room or elsewhere,
are thinking about how
they get on the journey
or what this journey
might look like for them.
All of you have practical
experience doing this
in sometimes many forms,
in an accelerated form,
particularly at Lucid, you know,
you gotta have some practical advice
based on the lessons learned
even out of the gate.
If you can think of just one thing
that you might wanna share with people
who are considering going
down a similar journey,
what would that one thing that
you might share with them?
I don't think there's a wrong answer here.
So, no pressure.
- You wanna start?
- I would say move quickly, move fast,
but this space is changing,
but first, get the executive
sponsorship and alignment ASAP,
and then prioritize, I mean
identify your pain points
and make sure you're prioritized,
'cause you won't be able to
address every single sort
of use case over there.
So based on your sort of, you
know, priority, move quickly.
- I would just add, make it personal.
One of the key learnings I have is,
everyone's afraid of change.
And when we're talking about data,
there's a lot of security concerns.
But when I would set up
meetings or talk with the people
who were hesitant to
allow this or enable it,
they were on board.
We just had to make that human connection
and make sure that everyone
was on the same page.
And once they were,
whether it be internal audit
or anyone else, they were like,
oh, oh, okay, sure, no problem.
I understand now.
And so just make sure you check that box
and not just try to pass it
because it's a little, it
takes time, it does, you know,
require conversation and what have you,
but once you unlock that,
it really will help.
- And Wil, you mentioned it earlier,
I think you've gotta be
comfortable waking up tomorrow
that your job is changing.
I always look at the, it's
an interesting moment,
and I was talking to my adult kids.
Like, you gotta lean in, right?
Like, the people that are not lean,
if you are in a white-collar job
and you are not leaning
into AI, that's a mistake.
Your job will not exist as it does today.
So one of the things
as leaders in the room,
as individuals and as
mentors to the people
that are around us, we have no
choice but to be a role model
in terms of understanding the technology,
thinking through use cases,
thinking through how fast
can I disrupt the business?
And thinking about how
to unlock creativity
that can improve the
growth strategy associated
with the companies.
- I have a really quick
story to add on that note.
At the very beginning of the
project, I took a flight,
I was in the ILC and I
could see the gentleman,
his laptop screen across from me.
And I knew it from 30 seconds in,
I knew he was in finance
because he has this spreadsheet
with tables and the tables
have like red and green
and he's capturing it on
a, you know, snapshot.
And then he flips over to PowerPoint,
pastes it on the slide, expands it,
and then starts writing bullet points
to accompany the tables.
And I just thought to myself,
and I went back and the
team knows I said this,
I know that guy's gonna be a dinosaur
if he doesn't change the way he works.
I knew exactly what he was doing.
He didn't have to say anything.
I just saw his screen.
I was familiar with that.
I've done it for decades.
And knowing that he's
still operating like that,
it has to change or he's
gonna get passed by.
- Right.
- Last thing I would add is,
is finding those people
in the organization
that can help be the change
agents and think big.
You know, I think about,
I've done a lot of work
with airlines and you know,
one of the issues that this airline
had was that they were way
over on budget, on crew labor.
And so it was a finance issue
and we started deconstructing
it, working through it.
I spoke to the head of
flight ops the other day
and they'll save $200 million this year
based upon developing a tool
to figure out the forecast,
which then led to, oh, we
can schedule different,
we can align crew different,
we can, and no, no, no.
They just start taking
it forward and forward,
and you need those people
in the organization
that are willing to challenge those norms
'cause that's where the
real value is going to be,
not just in the efficiencies,
it's what different,
what can we do operationally different,
what insights can we get, et cetera.
- I was just gonna add to Wil's comment.
Like, I think that the,
one of the use cases we have
is exactly to leverage some
of our board decks and
our sort of slidewares
to be able to populate
exactly not just the data,
but also the commentary.
There is an executive dashboard
that has been, you know,
as a use case been created,
which will, you know,
based on the users, whether
it's a CEO, it's a different,
you know, use case,
and whether it's a CFO
at different use case,
whether it's a, you know, finance leader,
it's a different use case,
but they get sort of the
commentary on a daily basis,
not like a Tableau dashboard,
but they get all the
metrics with the commentary
and it allows them to sort of navigate
and have almost conversational analytics.
Okay, here are your red areas,
here are your, you know,
pain points, tell me
what's going on over there,
which, why is it this way?
Why has the ASP gone down or
what, you know, which area,
what triggered that sort of,
you know, headwind and whatnot?
So I mean, back to your
point, as you said,
like, we're already doing that.
So, it's a good call out.
- The context that it
provides is critical, right?
Like, we could spend a whole
nother session on context.
I just wanna say thank
you to the panelists.
A refreshing conversation
is a little bit different
than a lot of the conversations
that we have at re:Invent.
So thank you for just investing the time,
sharing your expertise.
I wanna say thank you
for just the opportunity
to be your partner on this journey.
We're truly honored.
And then for everyone,
audience, and up here,
just wishing you a fantastic
remainder of your re:Invent.
Thank you for spending time with us.